Oprah Aladin Han Solo we've got the
biggest highlights from d23 Plus SIA
ditches for wig and we are shook and
finally my interview with Tina friggin
Knowles I know this is the daily Jennie
I'm Denny direct oh and you guys thought
I had a big head before but this weekend
I got a chance to chat with Beyonce's
mom Tina Knowles Lawson it's the first
time we've heard from her since the
babies were born so on a scale from one
to my head this is huge so now that the
world has been introduced to Beyonce and
jay-z twins how are mom and dad
adjusting to life at home and what's the
deal with their names
well I got it all when I spoke with
proud grandma Tina at the hollyrock
Foundation's annual design care event
world was finally introduced to those
beautiful grand babies of yours I mean
you guys just must be over the moon yeah
we are very excited you know there was
some confusion over the names to help me
clear it up we've got a girl named
roomie and a boy named well you know one
baby is a lot of work I can't imagine -
Howard jay-z and Beyonce adjusting to
life at home with three kids now well I
mean it's exciting you know it's a
wonderful experience yeah you know you
can't forget the firstborn right how do
I be doing as a big sister she enjoying
her younger sibling teri proud and very
excited that because she's a great big
yeah she really cares for them a lot
doesn't miss Tina look like Christmas
morning anyway grandma wasn't ready to
give up the meaning behind the names
Rumi and sir but here's what we learned
about them Rumi is a 13th century poet
and over the weekend Tina instagrams
some of his most popular quotes
including love is the bridge between you
and everything and of course the name
sir well that suggests royalty and power
so you better watch that throne Sir
Carter speaking of the throne I also
asked Tina what she thought of her
son-in-law jay-z's new album and she
said it was art and was not surprised by
how candid he was about his relationship
you can catch more of my interview with
Tina Knowles often tonight on ET and
right now on e t-- online.com but moving
on to some big movie news coming out of
these annual d23 Expo in Anaheim
California Ichi was there this past
weekend and so was a favorite of the
daily Denny a resident movie expert Ashe
process and the air so I loved it you
had a very busy week in my friend busy
but exciting there was so much to get
excited about including the first look
at a wrinkle in time yes I was there
inside when Oprah and co-stars Reese
Witherspoon and Mindy Kaling debuted
that teaser trailer everyone was so
hyped from it I needed the futuristic
makeup the costumes everything about it
visually not to mention Oprah wetzel
Oprah and everyone started chanting
Oprah during the presentation because
she handed out posters like this you get
a poster you go get a poster you'll get
a poster everybody gets a pulse on
Grammy oh thank you for my poster
ostraka I love it Annie G caught up with
Oprah Rhys and Mindy at the convention
where they told our Cameron Mathison
about their bond behind-the-scenes we
had a lot of major conversations in the
hair makeup room every morning Reese was
head DJ down at the in chair playing I
mean music that I hadn't heard since
1945 and who knew that she had all this
soul sister in her and Al Green was
rocking us out and so we're whole lot of
other people but it was an incredible
experience just to be with each other
and to share in this sort of newfound
adventure right so generous you know I
will say the two of them are known for
the generosity but it's not just
generous or things that they want to
share from you know physically with you
their favorite English muffins there's a
review various entertainment makeup
friends but also with advice and life
experience you just come in and every
day I learn something incredible okay
now I know last week you and I were
talking about the reported tasking drama
for the Aladdin live-action and I we
predicted we got some answers and it
appears all of that trouble finding the
leaves was BL totally they even said on
stage some of the things you've heard
are untrue and then they revealed the
two actors on top to play Prince Ali and
Princess Jasmine so main on the sued
scored the coveted role of the Prince of
Thieves
while Power Ranger star Naomi Scott will
play jasmine now Meena is still a
relative newcomer with only a few movie
roles on his resume but we also learned
the
big star stepping into Robin Williams
shoes as bikini is in fact going to be
Will Smith so it looks like Guy Ritchie
got his first choice I honestly cannot
wait for this movie and I know film you
are really excited about of course is
the untitled Han Solo project oh man and
I was certain that d23 was going to be
be han solo movies PR comeback after the
director snafu but they barely touched
it it was mentioned briefly and kind of
awkwardly no news no updates those today
the movies new director Ron Howard
shared this pic from set and look who it
is
a young glamorous Chewbacca Chewie and I
love it where we shall have high hopes
for that thing and at d23 by the way was
this massive just we until we head to
Comic Con ash will be there I will be
there and we are bringing you guys along
with us we'll be live from San Diego
comic-con starting Thursday so they so
stay tuned and thank you for something
but you and San Diego are you guys
before we sign out today I've got to
show you this new photo of SIA the
chandelier singer ditched her go to look
on Friday opting for a fresh face and
her natural blonde locks I'm telling you
I had to do a double take and get this
she was busy meeting up with Kate Hudson
rumor has it the two are working on a
musical that SIA is directing so far
neither Kate norcia have confirmed the
project but it's worth noting that just
last week Kate posted a pic with Sears
Muse Maddie Ziegler and captioned it
dance rehearsal but this bundle of
excellence well whatever they are
collaborating on I am here for it hi
folks that is it for now we will be back
tomorrow with some more good good until
then be sure to hit subscribe to e t--'s
youtube channel and as always head over
to ET online.com to catch the latest in
the entertainment world alright i'm a
bauble my way out of here naive